yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
and today we're gonna be talking about
no man's sky which is right around the
corner if you've been at least a little
bit active around the game inside of the
internet these past couple months or
even the past two years if you want to
go all the way back to the start you
probably heard about this game no man's
sky the procedurally generated space
explorer survival game and chances are
you've seen people either relentlessly
praising this not yet released game or
already condemning it to be a failure
comparable to the likes of spore so with
all this intense polarization
surrounding the game how can we tell if
it will live up to the hype or
disappoint on a grand scale well we can
start by looking at why people are so
split about the game the hype train sees
the game as the trailers have made it
seen a gigantic procedurally generated
galaxy or maybe even universe that holds
18 quintillion planets limitless variety
and endless discovery it's the ultimate
sci-fi exploration survival game that
gives the player unparalleled immersion
and the side of extreme cynics views the
game as smoke and mirrors having had
multiple delays and no clear answer to
the infamous question what do you even
do no man's sky all the limitless
variety will be slightly different copy
and pasted models and the lack of
content will quickly mark the game as a
failure now I've made some sweeping
generalizations about both sides here
there are a lot of rational people on
either side of the spectrum people who
are excited about the game without
getting carried away by the height and
people who are reasonably skeptical
about such bold claims coming from such
a small dev team hello games the
creators of no man's sky only has 15
members I see the game as having the
potential to fulfill either prophecy
I'll be probably a more toned down
version of either one there has been a
lot of hype without much being revealed
about the game for the past two years
and it's hard to believe that such a
small group will be able to produce
something so massive in scale however
with the recent set of trailers being
fight to survive trade and explore I
feel we're starting to finally get some
concrete info and examples about what
the game is really going to be except
for the fight trailer screw that one
there was better combat fighting in the
Explorer trailer than there was in the
fighting trailer is looking like it
could really deliver on being a
large-scale truly immersive space
exploring game
really though we'll have to rate until
reviews and the actual release of the
game currently the game is set to
release on August ninth or 12 and I
haven't heard anything about review
copies or viewers putting out reviews of
the game on the day of launch or
beforehand and that is a possibility of
being a bad sign but we can't know yet I
put myself closer to the hype side of
the game but still some healthy
skepticism the game does look like it's
going to be a lot of fun but it could
easily be repetitive lackluster and kind
of boring I'm definitely going to be
getting game and I'll be letting you
guys know what I think of it when it
comes out let me know in the comments
what you guys are expecting of the game
will it rock little suck will it deliver
will it fail so that will basically wrap
up the video thank you for watching if
you like the content i will be making
more no man's sky content as the game
comes out and as more news about it
comes out in these coming days before
release to all my viewers who came in
here off Dark Souls and are watching
this long I will be making more Dark
Souls content when the dlc comes out and
that should be sometime this fall so
expect that however in the meantime if
you guys are excited about no man's sky
I will probably be doing a lot of
content about that and maybe even some
lower concerning that since there might
be some cool or to make that and people
have responded well to my lower videos
well that should be it thank you for
watching visa